hey guys it's november seventh also
known as n7 day for you mass effect fans
I'm chasity and I've got your news let's
kick off on 7 day with Mass Effect
Andromeda there's a new trailer and
details on the deluxe edition Bioware
released a new cinematic trailer for
Andromeda today that you can check out
in full on gamespot com the narrator
writers father sets up the video with
this description we slept for hundreds
of years dreaming of a new home but when
we finally awoke our dreams of peace
were shattered it was also confirmed
today that more Andromeda gameplay will
be shown during the game awards in
December additionally Game Informer
reveals that writers father is voiced by
Clancy Brown who voices mr. Krabs and
SpongeBob and also appeared in
Highlander and the Shawshank Redemption
amazon listings for Angelina's deluxe
edition have gone live revealing the
names but not the specifics of its
contents it comes with the Pathfinder
casual outfit scavenger armor Pathfinder
elite weapon set pet pie Jack digital
soundtrack and a multiplayer deluxe
launch pack the page references to
pre-order bonuses the deep space
explorer armor and a multiplayer booster
pack that provides five fifty percent
experience boosters an early relief for
angela's box art says the game is for
one player or up to four in multiplayer
Bioware hasn't said much about mass
effec Andromeda's multiplayer in an
official capacity but it has been
mentioned in previous leaks keep
checking out gamespot com for more
reveals and announcements on Andromeda
from n7 day next up a fun tribute to a
call of duty for glitch in modern
warfare remastered the 2007 original
call of duty 4 modern warfare contained
a glitch on one of the maps we're under
the right circumstances you could slip
out of the map now that modern warfare
remastered is out it's been discovered
that developer Raven Software paid
tribute to this glitch by putting a
caution sign over the area where this
could happen this was discovered
recently by reddit user de Jerian and
highlighted by Kotaku this glitch was a
pretty wild one as it caused players to
slip into another dimension basically
the new caution sign is a pretty cool
easter egg for fans of the franchise to
come across modern warfare remastered
officially launched on November fourth
for playstation 4 xbox one and pc and
the only way to get it is to buy one of
the premium versions of Call of Duty
infinite warfare which started at eighty
dollars as of yet Activision has not
said if it will ever release the
remaster on its own
but also hasn't ruled it out and finally
a Pokemon go update with daily catch
bonuses and more Pokemon goes newest
feature has arrived the new update now
adds the daily catch bonus feature that
niantic labs announced last week players
will earn bonuses for their first
Pokemon catch and visit to app okay stop
every day if you do this seven days in a
row you'll get even bigger bonuses the
patch also tweaks some gym systems and
makes minor text fixes in addition to
launching the new patch niantic
confirmed it is testing out a new
version of the nearby Pokemon feature
this is already live in San Francisco
that is now being expanded to parts of
Arizona as well as the Seattle area and
the rest of the San Francisco Bay Area
we will continue to review community
feedback make changes if necessary and
roll this feature out to more regions
the developer said mantic did not
provide any kind of timetable for when
the nearby Pokemon feature will be
available nationwide or in other parts
of the world let me know what you think
of today's stories in the comments below
and don't forget this Friday we have
extra life it's going down friday to
sunday for 72 hours in three different
continents it's our charity event where
we're raising money for the kids so
please check it out and donate and i'll
see you next time